du könntest theoretisch guck mal jockey
heißt schockiert töten jetzt die spinne
schön mit rotem haar direkt legende und
wir sind dieses mal mit den koffer
unterwegs
manu käfer sind deine pläne erstmal für
diese folge fiel blutet und wie du ich
weiß ein bisschen der stadt öfter
gestorben als ich sehe ich gerade ja ja
ich bin in der stadt durch ja und zwar
sehr statisch und sehe was ich
angefangen habe zu bauen und dann zeigt
ja schon wenn ich bin ja der
waffenmeister ich habe dafür zu sorgen
dass unsere truppe angriffs bereit ist
und sich die anderen in die windel
kacken ein sie nur unsere waffen sehen
sich potentielle waffenkammer des schoko
bord kann eine feder ausgeschieden
ja ich habe ein gelbes türkei wo gelder
und außerdem meine lieben freunde das
hier ist nicht ok deswegen können wir
dieses niveau ganz ungetrübt einfach
töten weil das nicht okay ist weil
brothers hat und nicht hat uns nicht
jockey zurückgegeben also du musst
wissen
rocky ist man sowohl das habe ich so
genannt sondern die haben ja so ein
anderes doofes zurückgegeben deswegen
konnten wir es ist ganz einfach töten
das ist mir allerdings erst jetzt
aufgefallen und mir wurden ich habe
jetzt endlich mal dazu ermutigt
kommentare zu lesen
und deswegen werde ich nun ja ich habe
mir jetzt endlich mal richtig viel
kommentare durchgelesen tipps etc
und da wurde mir sondern bis zu kaufen
sondern abgeschrieben der ich ein den
ich eigentlich schon so was von längst
wissen müsste nämlich dass man wenn man
zombie fleisch verbrennt dass man lena
bekommt aber jetzt habe ich schon 50
leder von afrika
wollen wir auch gesagt obwohl ich das
wusste dummerweise ich würde mir das
wirklich trotzdem wurden jetzt mal
vergessen hatte ja das ist bei mir auch
nicht vergessen so viele sachen vor
allem dich durch exit und so vergisst du
soviel er diese neuen crafting rezepte
einfach drin das weiße verstehe ich
völlig war mir auch so es ist echt crazy
so wenn du dir erstmal anschauen möchte
ist natürlich herzlich eingeladen
ja du ich will eigentlich von mir aus
nächste folge dann komme ich da eine
frage seit ich musste erst mal bauen ich
orientiere mich herab ich habe zwar
gesagt dass ich mich so an so einer
römischen waffen halle orientiere aber
ich hab mal gegoogelt römische sachen
lager oder so und so was gibt's gar
nicht
das für mich so ein antiken griechischen
römischen stil schon ich sehe schon ach
so das sehr schön und ihr roboter mit
verzauberung zwischen gleich alles
hatten also ich finde wir sind am
organisierten von allen städten wo ich
das am anfang nicht gedacht hätte das
ist irgendwie alles so gekommen nachdem
könig wurde und zombie dazu gekommen
alles gute entscheidung das hat das
irgendwie ich bin irgendwie stolz auf
uns ich bin zwar noch nicht so produktiv
aber ich versuche jetzt wenigstens so
was zusätzlich auf eine vollständige
skelett richtung wo alles vertraut ist
ja das wollte ich auch noch machen und
zwar wollte ich mir keine scale rüstung
machen sondern eine trial rüstung was
soll damit könntest du ab dadurch dass
sowieso in die kisten tun würde ich werd
ist geil bist du schon für immer
behalten kann es bei mir natürlich hier
schauen also was ganz heißen wie das
thema anschaust bei mir ist sozusagen so
eine art mitarbeiter eingang zu meinem
haus tritt hier geben ich habe jetzt
erst mal blau show geboten zwar habe ich
erfolge sagt ich um ein grünes
allerdings dachte ich mir ich werd wohl
nicht so oft berge über reisen als ich
irgendwie ins wasser will deswegen
gestern blau ist für mich erst mal
sinnvoller und da die alle schon von
comics gesehen wurden muss ich jetzt
einfach hier so ein ding draufsetzen
allerdings möchte ich möchte ich ein
männliches sondern weiblich ist hätte
ein weißes wir haben weißes schoko
albino j
wir haben ein weißes alter in warin
alter in dem weißes warte das hat
normalerweise für fähigkeiten
weiß es hat richtig krasse sachen
lightshow co
ich glaub ich nehme den hier an der ecke
sei leute ich finde hier die mitte grad
nicht soweit chocobos everyday table
moped biografie wartet schoko kraft zur
geburt golden boy cottbus kennt kleine
band swing fest
biallo.at watte es geht schon los die
schwimmen können so ist ein schock
obwohl landtag ja ach so was hab ich im
livestream 5 coupé leute und er hat
sogar so komisch
regenbogen sachen dann sind es ist ein
weibchen also wir haben jockey zurück
wie war etwa das ist das wird mir
erklären ich kann mich nur noch mit
schoko bus ach so ja du musst gut
annehmen weil wir haben da so ein großes
puzzle feld und du musst dann auf einen
kokon so lange drauf machen bis es dich
halt mag ja aber wenn zum beispiel in
grünes kaka ein grünes bringt das duo
zwei blöcke hochklettern kann also berge
hoch klettern klasse dass du schnell
durch wasser reiten kannst das wollte
ich mir eigentlich holen gelb ist ganz
normal dass da nix ausarbeiten
weiß ist und weiß ist ein gutes aber da
ist glaube ich nur noch ein weiß was im
sattel hat und das glaube ich zombie
aber mir wurde gesagt dass ich mir ein
weißes neben darf bzw irgendeines nehmen
darf weiter von broken flowers 1
genommen wurde
warum sind bei mir denn über diese
doofen portal geschirr und umgehen ist
ich weiß nicht ich habe mich in der
symmetrie verstrickte ich glaube ich
weiß auch nicht wie ich das bei mir noch
bauen soll
ich wollte doch eigentlich in der
nächsten folge gehe ich mal auf existenz
und goldsucher weil jetzt wollte ich mir
erst mal ein paar andere sachen kräften
und zwar was wolltest du noch mal mit
der triba lama was ich mir dabei wohl
der minister du kannst gerne haben mag
ist danach schauen weil ich das wiso
hier verschenken würde ob ich
irgendeinen teil davon schon ab das
kannst du natürlich dann schaltet also
das einzige was sie brauchen sind extra
existenz ist ein bisschen wertvoll sind
das anderes also leder und von kaka
sonst hast du glaub ich nicht welcher
kiste denn ach so höre ich die
mitarbeiter eingang bildet hier oben
einmal und hier
länderspiel ein schild verändern wenn er
mehr das ist was am bogen
was bringt ein goldener bogen
ich teste war die bögen und sagt wir
dann die wirkung von den also ich habe
auf jeden fall ein legia boden schießt
eins bis drei pfeile gleichzeitig das
kind erwartet longo das passt hier vorn
und hinten el
und jetzt weiß ich auch wieso ich habe
ja gar nicht symmetrisch gebaut
ich habe richtig kacke gebaut spannen
die mit witz und zwar werde ich das ist
einfach hier so ein weiterbauen höre ich
das ein bisschen besser so die pfeile
nämlich wenn wir mit dass ihr wird re
wies kakao ziehen
hallo war lange habe ich das gemacht so
dass du dort fast nie ich muss das doch
irgendwie anders waren so und zwar hab
ich mich hier verbaut weil hier sind
sechs zwischen und ihren fünf zwischen
und da er gerade und gerade nicht
kombinierbar ist mancher wach auf 673
fans etwas zu klein aber nicht um gerade
und ungerade und das kann man besser im
baum kombinieren und ich denke einfach
ein fall ändert seien sword das
verschenkt du klar was bringt dann ein
entertainment sport das ist männersport
oder und des preises wien
ich weiß nicht genau wo die unterschiede
sind also ist auch egal wie das schild
und erstes mal weisen aber aus bedarf
wenn sie gefällt also ich benutze
persönlich selber auch und ändert giants
ordner
ach so ja cool also sehen kann
eigentlich gerne nutzen wir eigentlich
mega zufrieden mit meinem namen sport
aber ändert giants worte sich nochmal
episch an broken flowers meinte dazu mir
dass ich wegen dem toggenburg glauben
mir irgendwas bei denen neben darf was
ich möchte deswegen ich habe überlegt
was die eventuell haben könnten sowas
sich lohnen würde überhaupt zu plündern
ja deswegen ich habe mir gedacht
irgendeine essenz was wäre wenn du warst
electric elefanten nix anderes warum
weil die witwe hoch tauschen kann
ich habe jede ist ich hab sogar magic
essenzen für eine magic sands brauchst
du acht verschiedene lizenzen aber ich
brauche halt electrical ist das etwas
bringen das tanzen kann zauberstäbe
drogba stehen jetzt egal wie mache ich
mir so ein flug zauberstab kann ich dir
auch gerne mal ehrlich wenn du zwei
elektriker des seins mitbringst damalige
ein und mir einige nämlich eine
vollmacht auch so und ich mir nur eine
und dann mach ich die sache also
electrical essenzen also leute das was
ich gerade mache ist alles legal wenn
ihr das überhaupt haben uns egal warum
kriegt ja nicht wann die extra gesperrt
damit nicht ran kommst gefängnis
mindestens braucht man die nicht für so
ein stoff was bringt eine winter sense
ist unwichtig weil sie den zauberstab
aber schlecht sind also keine als
wirklich gut auch selber feuer
zauberstab gegen zauberstab und fliege
zauberstab okay die haben aber glaube
ich nichts die haben whatever also die
haben sich da nie im leben alles
geklappt wir sind einfach nur um
geflogen bestimmt offenbar diese einfach
nur in allem in dungeons regeln so hier
läuft das jetzt auch ihr seht dass hier
gerade ich baue das hier aus weil die
märkte schon wenn das hier ein weiter
hier ist dann passt das endlich auch
sagte meine ganzen instanzen die ich
habe wind essence darkness and fire
essenspausen es sind aber auch fire es
denn es ist auch gut oder
ich habe von lizenzen also wie kannst du
so nicht nutzen
bombay und und voila dreier
die machen ja live stream quintessenz
ist es was bringt der water ist ein eis
essen
ich habe alle fans da also ich hab alle
essenzen lizenzen ja alle instanzen
außer elektrischen das im überfluss also
daran merkt schon wie wertvoll die
analysten
die amerikaner setzen die nehme ich mir
so
hamster dafür richtig diese natürlich
gut da das ist die rache dafür dass ihr
mir einfach mal chocobo cloud dafür
packt ihr in einen pinguin kopf daran
dass ist die neuen ist dafür was nehmen
und dann geben sind die so dreist dann
geht mir nicht nur ein richtiges chocobo
zurück dass und das nach sieben folgen
das ist ja wohl camp ist es mehr als
gerechtfertigt ja klar
weil das war auch ein verstoß gegen die
regeln muss die berge möchten ganz klar
dämpfe geschrieben damit haben wir
sowieso nicht zu entscheiden was die
strafe ist das hat der könig zu
entscheiden
hast du müsstest die rein theoretisch
gar nicht fragen nun mal so eigentlich
aber du bist ja so viel und so stadt
treu dass da einfach wird das trikot mit
dem sattel hitler das genommen was
keinen sattel hatte durfte mir ja eins
nehmen wegen malz und mangels weg danke
zombie familienanwesen spieler bei zwölf
runden komme gerade so voran mit dem
bauen also ich habe etliche fehler
ausgemerzt aber jetzt passt es auch von
der symmetrie endlich so diamond 2
eigentlich immer rauer aber wenn ist
immer ich da sagt auch wenn eigentlich
kein keinem wehtut tut als ob sagst du
wirklich immer rauer
immer noch hat sich zum beispiel eine
zweite hand oder so mit dem der dann so
ärgert oder so oder was so am laufen ist
fast schlägt nein wenn man keine ahnung
sagte auermann gekitzelt wird oder so
ich sag das nicht hat mich auch nicht so
verbreitet
ich schreibe so eine klare sagt der ob
auf dauer sagt es fast nie ohne witz
nicht weh aber ich sag's einfach holz
genannt lustig wirklich gerade la la la
la da soll ich mein material machen was
mit service wieder zu empfehlen oder das
passt ja widerlich
also ich kenne die meteor sachen leider
gar nicht muss ich sagen ja das ist ja
immer auf zwei leute die sache ist wenn
man in vent hat voll ist und ich weiß
dass eine axt in dann fliegt die um mich
herum und dann nehme ich irgendwann
wieder auf das ganz gut wenn man im
winter voll deswegen mehr zusammen sagt
ganz gut in der relativ selten bei
meteore meteoriten der welten abstürzt
und diesen wirklich selten aber ich weiß
nicht ob die so gut sind dass es in das
teil das ding das teil ist für mich
zurzeit gar keine wälder kaputt gegangen
ich weiß gar nichts wenn ich meinen
damaligen ob ich bin dabei hat ihr alles
zu sortieren und entwicklung nicht das
ist auch außen stehen das heißt das wird
so sein
er passt läuft muss und mir auch sehr
häufig geschrieben wurde bekannt sachen
mit seiner verzaubern und dann kriegst
du die beim
stern zurück habe ich habe meine
komplette leistung ist sollte er
vertraut was mit den ökonomischen page
es gar nicht gehört naja du hast
komplett verzaubert aber solche so etwas
über welche macht egal was ein was
bringt eine homepage das weiß ich selbst
nicht erbringen
zu den magic mirror nehme ich mit schoko
pda wenn ich jetzt einen schoko an was
geiles es passt in copiapo pda ist
schoko benennen ich habe fünf stück
davon
ja da kannst du musst unbedingt fall
gehen und den einfach gewinnen das weiß
ich nicht
sydney schon change könnte es
theoretisch aber kommt mal tokio könnte
es theoretisch glaube ich wenn du damit
mal rechtsklick auf den job machst
einfach so den besitzer ändern
chiquita und wirklich ja ich will ja ich
will das jetzt nicht ausreizen
wir wissen am baum übrigens leute ich
hab die face kempf erstellt wieder oben
links und wenn ich ein mob angucke ist
das jetzt nicht nach oben links sondern
das ist jetzt oben rechts neben der
karte das hab ich jetzt eigentlich
relativ sterne da sind sternen gelandet
haben will
hab schon wem ich das macht da ist
einfach mal simon kuper eindringling
creeper alter dimensions wort macht
glaube ich mehr schaden
ich will gar nicht sicher ob ich jetzt
wieder reine mein haus schnell ich hab
noch ein star ist übrigens aus dem neuen
star pieces kann ich mir so ein großer
star blog machen und daraus wenn ich in
den mit park und außenraum obsidian dann
mache ich mir sorgen sondern bieten blog
den ställen der leuchtet einfach doppelt
keine spezielle fähigkeit öl wird mir
gerade zwei getränke doch glaube ich
jetzt mal zu 700 mitarbeiter
was denn wolfgang explosion gehört noch
ein stapel ja habe ich aber auch schon
wieder
denn schon direkt daneben heute ist
richtige sternschnuppen nach sehr guten
job obwohl etliche schpakow strohmann
alter das geile ist wusstest du hast
eine verzauberung tisch reparieren kann
für level wie kann für level reparieren
so anziehsachen und so was alles
reparieren
aber da wollte ich jetzt eben dran und
wollte mit soul verzaubern so ist weiß
ehrlich gesagt nicht weiter ins bett
gehen das wird aber nicht nur zu 15 auf
keinen fall was sie findet doch bisher
auch diesen zwischen wünsche mir gefällt
nicht ignorieren steelers marburg cappel
stone
bactech drei farblich gut aus aber als
dach wäre das glaube ich gut wir alle
uns mit unserem element kracht
entkräftet
ja das ist richtig viel drauf verzaubert
schade dass drei noch beck zwei mutigen
falls ja ich hab holz kommt einfach mal
mit zu ihren alltag
doch der zimmer wohnungen dass eine böse
spende kiwi töten jetzt zu spinnen schön
mit rotem hoy ich bin heute glaube ich
richtig ihn richtig hohe lebenserwartung
hat sich richtig gefreut zudem sei das
meint eigentlich waren hätten dann töte
ich dir einfach im video zwar ein
bisschen der macht da nicht mehr so viel
zeit noch in die kiste und den cup sieg
alles andere übels scheiße aus beim wenn
mama mit babbel baut man mit marvel bei
der zürcher so was ich auch noch machen
wollte war da da da da da
wo habe ich denn hier passt das
eigentlich ganz gut findet was heute
machen das ja das volk in die häfen tun
so ein bisschen vollständigkeit halber
zu hier sollte am besten ein glos
dorthin bekomme ich hier den nabel raus
und da ja den werde ich dann nochmal
damit wäre ich dann vier stück zum break
machen und diesen mark bric werde ich
dann bei mir im keller packen und ich
würde sagen wir sind schon wieder bei
den 20 minuten weg angekommen ja
wunderbar ich geh jetzt eben vom server
unter wenigen noch eine folge zusammen
oft langweilig gewesen macht aber nichts
denn wie gesagt muss das ja irgendwie
fertig kriegen und wir sehen uns aber in
der nächsten folge leute bleibt ganz gut
bist ein schatz